okay a DMC surrogate flipping the script
on Republicans who claim crime is out of
control and democrat-led cities Madison
Wisconsin's Democratic mayor blasting
the notion that America is in Decline
under President Biden
anybody thinks that this country is in
Decline
come to cities
because Democratic Mayors all across the
nation are creating great places where
people want to be where growth is
happening and where our economy is
growing
we don't have a lot of time so all of
you let her rip yeah Greg okay well I
mean I hate to amplify something in the
break but you said you said you said to
me this woman isn't fit to be mayor and
that uh how could she just look out the
window like a mug shot yeah like a
mugshot it probably is one yeah yeah of
her yeah judge okay look she doesn't
know what she's talking about because
the largest number of people moving out
of democratic cities are moving to
Republican states so moving from
California Illinois Michigan
Massachusetts and New York to Texas
Florida Carolina's Virginia Tennessee I
rest my case Dana well I was just in
Milwaukee and we had that voter panel I
mentioned those nine people and I in the
commercial break we asked them how how
is crime here and to a person they said
this is not good it's terrible actually
and then we interviewed the mayor of
Dallas on Monday and he was the one who
said that he's got number one safest
city in Gallup this year and he's a
black Democratic mayor how did he do it
a complete focus on police arresting
repeat offenders and they are Off to the
Races and hats off to him she should pay
attention to what he's doing sounds like
a model example yes when the Democrats
in the White House the country's in
Decline when the Republicans in the
White House the country is doing great
that's how it works on both sides but
you can't deny the fact that people are
leaving the cities because it's a
catastrophe point I left the city
and we cry every day about it I want to
Brian kill Mead I want you to do me a
favor I want you to click to subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube page this is the
only way that I know for sure that
you're not going to miss any great
commentary any great news bites any
great interviews coming your way on Fox
you can get it all here on YouTube so
subscribe right now